you know I saw you a couple of weeks ago
in New York they had this big TNT TBS
lunch yes and uh and it was it was
actually turned out for one of those
events where that we're all supposed to
show up at that was a real fun it was a
nice lunch with like 200 of us and I
ended up at a table with Conan and uh
Angie Harmon and Sasha Alexander so yeah
Conan O'Brien and I were double dating
with Rizzoli and Isles yeah which was
very exciting I've had that I've had
that dream before yes did you know which
was which
okay don't ask they they still fight him
I know yeah yeah so uh so it was a very
fantastic it was fun Steve Carell was
there I know you were I was there a
little bit well I don't I know Steve a
little bit from school we're parents at
the same school uh and I saw him at this
other table and I thought I'm gonna I'm
gonna do something fun so I went to one
of the waiters I said I wanna I wanna
pretend to bring the bill for this
entire lunch to Steve Carell can I have
one of those little sleeves and it was a
launch of let's be clear 200 people 200
yeah 200 celebrities and Executives and
writers all in one exactly so I said can
I have one of those little billfolds and
the waiter said hell I can I can give
you a bill is it really you see whenever
the machine he said for how much I said
240 dollars and he said how many cents I
said 71.
so that's what you think they put in the
thing I took it over to Steve and I just
walked up to the table you know my best
Major D and I said um whenever you're
ready there's no rush
and he
and he of course pure Buster Keaton
Steve he looks up and went oh I I didn't
is this and I said
that's my understanding
[Laughter]
and so either it was a perfect comic
moment or Steve Carell is really pissed
yeah I think he probably had to pay I
think he had to pay or that restaurant
got paid twice yeah yeah he's a big tip
for this now you flew to New York you
you flew with Andy there's a bunch of
you yes you guys flew together today TNT
and TBS they put together a plane with
everybody except you you refuse to fly
with the rest of us clearly but uh no
they had me go by train yeah everybody
everybody on the network I was in a
locomotive right right kind of spreading
across the country he's got digestive
issues yeah it's true you don't want to
be on a plane with me but songs tone and
everybody else was there and and it's
just it's this mix of like Steve bochko
is sitting beside CeeLo and Angie Harmon
is with Steve and I'm thinking this is
like a perfect episode like a special
episode of Survivor you know the TNT
plane emergency crash lands on an island
and you know like Lord of the Flies Andy
Richter becomes the king oh yeah
that's he would be coming he totally
would become king he's one of the
strongest guys I know I would I would
side with him you want to lean to you
got to come to me yeah
I think celo I also think celo would win
I think Sheila would be up to all kinds
of yeah JoBeth Williams also on the
plane you think about Poltergeist and a
poltergeist uh she's pretty tough too I
I can go that way uh this will be a
series by the way
I pitched it is this true that you are
friends with Elton John you're pretty
good uh well I'm I'm I'm I went to high
school with elton's partner with David
furnish in Toronto and uh and so yes we
uh we I haven't seen them a whole lot
lately but there was a time there was a
time on while you're asking this because
I was telling the story before that that
um my wife and I had Elton and David
over to our house for dinner that would
be I think a lot of pressure to have
Elton John over to your house my wife
and I live a pretty a pretty normal life
and and David phone one day and said hey
we're in town let's have dinner I said
great and my wife said have them over
have them over and she thought he was
just him I said he said okay Elton and
I'll be over Sunday
barbecue
you know how Elton loves barbecue
but we so we we uh we have divs just the
four of us my kid was just a little boy
at the time and uh we had a new piano so
I I had a few glasses when I said oh you
know after dinner you're gonna have to
Christen the piano and he got up God
bless him you got to be walked to the
next room he sat down put his fingers in
the keys and he said what would you like
me to play and I said and I wanted them
to know I'm a fan I'm a big fan I'm not
like here's tricky because if you say
the big obvious song you look you look
sort of square you say rocket man you'll
look like a putz so I figure I wanted to
know that I know so I said
I've seen that movie too from Goodbye
Yellow Brick Road and he looked up at me
and said
oh off I don't remember that song
[Applause]
and then he started playing rocket man
yeah
that's all he wants to play please
please it because what if his whole life
is everyone's being cool exactly no one
ever asked him to play I just want to
play your song exactly